if you don't acknowledge that emotions
weigh into all of your decisions even
your quote rational ones you are lost if
you're angry it's emotional if you're
insecure that's emotional if you have
emotions it decreases the speed with
that you make decisions and mistakes
love a rush decision the more you
believe in it or the more you want the
positive outcome to occur the more you
will purposefully blind yourself because
you want to save your ego and how you
feel it makes you feel good to think
about this positive outcome just why you
see other people because you can be
rational about others you see other
people make these terrible decisions and
you think to yourself why on God's Earth
would they make those decisions when in
reality that person is you and it's
other people who are looking at you